willkommen mein heutiger gast ist hier
um sie zu warnen vor psychologischen
kriegswaffen vor der politischen macht
von facebook und co ja vor einer
drohenden daten diktatur
sie weiß wovon sie spricht denn britney
kaiser arbeitete jahrelang führend bei
cambridge analytiker eben jener hightech
propaganda firma deren illegale
praktiken donald trump mutmaßlich ins
weiße haus verhalfen den br- exit mit
ermöglichten und untersuchungsausschüsse
in aller welt auf den plan riefen
frau kaiser es gibt viel zu klären und
zu verstehen schön dass sie da sind
danke für die einladung zum jahresanfang
2020 hat der guardian neuer enthüllungen
über cambridge analytiker ihren
ehemaligen arbeitgeber veröffentlicht
von 100000 dokumenten die rede von
beteiligungen teilweise auch illegalen
praktiken in über 70 ländern
diese gelegten veröffentlichen dokumente
stammen aus ihrem computer nicht war
richtig über den twitter kanal heinz
metternich am neujahrstag dokumente zu
veröffentlichen
mit dem ziel alle auf die globale daten
ausbeutung hinzuweisen die immer noch
stattfindet unsere daten sind nicht
sicher
die weltweit größte
kommunikationsplattform facebook setzt
nicht alles daran unsere daten zu
schützen
daher sind unsere demokratien in gefahr
das sind alles sehr wichtige große
themen wird sondern auf diese konkrete
publikation was sind dort an neuen
relevanten erkenntnissen im rahmen des
datenskandals der vor zwei jahren die
ganze welt bewegte cambridge analytiker
arbeitete er mindestens 50 ländern
weltweit und war in verhandlungen mit
weiteren 20 ländern
deshalb müssen die bürger aller länder
erfahren was während ihrer wahlen getan
wurde und was nicht
sie müssen wissen ob sie sicher sind
oder ob ihre daten noch mehr ausgebeutet
werden als ursprünglich an
zudem müssen sie die verschiedenen
strategien verstehen und wissen was
alles feilgeboten wird nicht nur für
wahlkampagnen sondern auch für
konsumenten werbung
hinzu kommen daten gesteuerte
psychologische operationen von
regierungen und militärs
wer die verschiedenen strategien nicht
durchschaut und weiß was alles angeboten
wird kann sich kaum vorstellen wie oft
wir ins visier genommen werden
doch das muss man verstehen damit man
sich informieren und etwas besser
schützen kann
und es ist ja wunderbar dass wir
jemanden hier haben der das alles von
innen gesehen hat nicht nur gesehen
sondern mit aufgebaut hat und dabei für
einen der größten politischen skandale
der letzten jahrzehnte gesorgt hat sagen
wir mal anfangen etwa zwei jahren im
frühjahr 2018 explodierte eine art bombe
es kam heraus dass cambridge analytiker
illegal daten gebraucht hatte in großer
in sehr großem umfang sie arbeiteten
damals noch für die firma es gab
enthüllungen und irgendwann im märz 2018
sind sie panikartig nach thailand
geflohen haben sich entschieden gegen
ihren arbeitsvertrag interna
auszuplaudern über diesen skandalösen
vorgänge was hat sie dazu bewogen
ich habe realisiert dass es sehr einfach
ist menschen zu manipulieren und dass
unsere daten missbraucht werden seit wir
begannen digitale geräte zu nutzen
ich finde es sehr wichtig dass die leute
wissen wie die ganze daten industrie
funktioniert unsere daten sind das
kostbarste gut auf der erde
doch wir die wir dieses gut produzieren
haben darauf keine rechte daten rechte
sollten heutzutage nicht nur mit den
menschenrechten gleichgesetzt werden wir
müssen auch berechtigt sein unsere daten
zu besitzen damit wir diesen besitz
schützen können
riecht land in ihr haus ein oder
beschädigt ihr auto können sie dagegen
vorgehen
aber wie sich gezeigt hat ist es sehr
schwierig in fällen von daten
kriminalität seine recht
einzufordern in diese metapher des
einbrechens ins haus aufzunehmen sie
waren teil dass einbrecher teams drei
jahre sie haben es mit geleitet mit
orchestriert aber es muss doch dann
einen punkt gegeben haben wo sie gesagt
haben jetzt reicht es jetzt dass genug
was hat diesen punkt in ihnen oder für
sie ausgelöst den ersten großen auslöser
erlebte ich einen monat nach trumps wahl
als meine früheren kollegen die für die
trump kampagne und eine lobbygruppe
super pack gearbeitet hatten uns in
einer zweitägigen präsentation darlegten
was sie getan hatten
dem wird mich ein ganzes kapitel in
meinem buch das auf deutsch erscheint
unter dem titel die daten diktatur darin
beschreibe ich wie meine ex kollegen
zwei tage lang über die von ihnen
gesammelten daten berichteten
sie erklärten wie sie die datenbank
aufgebaut und verletzliche oder
überzeugt bahre persönlichkeitstypen
identifiziert hatten und mit welchen
unterschiedlichen nachrichten und
strategien sie diese dazu brachten trump
zu wählen und wohl leider konnten sie
auch einige dazu bewegen gar nicht
wählen zu gehen
analytiker heute kennt dieses diese
firma fast jeder vor zwei jahren war sie
unter dem radar man hat gar nicht
gewusst was dort geschieht sie wurde
gegründet von einer person namens oder
geleitet vielmehr alexander nix wir
schauen uns den herrn ihrem boss für
drei jahre lang hier mal an und sie
wurde mit gegründet und finanziert von
einer anderen person nämlich steve
barron einem der köpfe und berater von
donald trump der auch dieser firma den
namen gegeben hat sie haben mit diesen
beiden personen von anfang an gearbeitet
und haben auch die deals die verträge
für die tram campaign an land gezogen
ist das richtig absolut ich ging mit
alexander nix zum erster patch in dem
trump tower wo wir uns mit karelien das
treffen
ja das war er wenn auch nicht verlangen
wir trafen uns also mit corey um ihm zu
erklären was wir tun konnten
denn damals arbeiteten nur 30 leute für
die tram kampagne
doch wenn sie gegen hillary clinton
antreten wollten mussten sie eine
nationale infrastruktur eine riesige
kampagne aufziehen so als wir unsere
möglichkeiten darlegten schaute ich
umher und sagte dieser raum kommt mir
bekannt vor obwohl ich noch nie im trump
tower war corey meinte klar scheint es
ihnen vertraut sie schauen wir prentis
nicht produziert hat uns da er war
mitten im meeting realisierte ich dass
ich auf dem set einer reality-tv-show
gelandet war und zu beginn der
verhandlungen ging es um eine daten
infrastruktur für den fernsehsender den
tram plante sie wollten ein
milliardenschweres medienunternehmen
aufbauen für das alle daten von trams
mal kampagne genutzt werden sollten
so konnte er die wirkung seiner
politischen botschaften an der
us-bevölkerung testen ihre wissen nach
ging es gar nicht darum präsident zu
werden sondern die
präsidentschaftskandidatur dazu zu
nutzen diese daten zu sammeln das war
das ziel genau er sammelte daten um
herauszufinden welche botschaften für
welche bürger geeignet waren
wie er ein publikum um sich sammeln und
aus diesem politischen zirkus ein
kommerzielles unternehmen machen konnte
profi können sie mir und 30 sekunden
erklären was cambridge analytiker so
besonders gemacht hat was sie gekonnt
haben was sonst niemand kommt die
wichtigste geheime zutat wie alexander
nix zu sagen pflegte war das psycho
grafische modeling und targeting das
heißt genau das heißt menschen über ihre
persönlichkeit zu identifizieren
danach wiesen welt sehen wie man sie
überzeugen kann wie man ihre gefühle
erreicht indem man menschen in
verschiedene kategorien unterteilt kann
man sie viel erfolgreicher überzeugen
dann erzielt eine viel größere wirkung
normalerweise 30 prozent mehr als über
traditionelle kommunikationsformen
leider basiert diese technik auf
militärische taktiken auf der
psychologischen kriegsführung
sie wird dort als sommerbauer eingesetzt
das heißt anstatt auf gewalt und waffen
zu setzen kann man eine bevölkerung
allein über die kommunikation dazu
bringen etwas zu tun oder zu lassen was
sie also getan haben in ganz spezieller
und elaborierter form ist von den daten
die es im internet über user gab
psychologische profile dieser person zu
erstellen und auf grund dieser
psychologischen profile ganz gezielt
eine ansprache zu wählen die auf diesen
persönlichkeitstyp ausgerichtet war
genau
zuerst dachte ich das ist eine
aufregende arbeit ich habe mich mein
leben lang als wahlkämpferin und
aktivistin engagiert die idee dass es
werkzeuge gibt mit denen ich menschen
dazu bringen kann sich für politik zu
interessieren sich registrieren zu
lassen um wählen zu können dass ich sie
für den klimawandel für die
krankenversicherungen die ausbildung der
kinder sensibilisieren kann fantastisch
leider ist das nicht die einzige
anwendung geheime soße die secret songs
die sie erwähnt haben
das war eine mischung aus datensätzen
und avancierten psychologischen theorien
wie das genau zusammengefunden hat das
schauen wir uns jetzt in einem kleinen
mann
wir teilen unser leben was wir mögen was
uns interessiert wo wir sind
alles wird digital verbreitet wir
vernetzen uns und das hinterlässt spuren
ja unzählige daten
das nutzt nun auch psychologen mit
unseren daten berechnen sie den kern
unseres wesens
zeige mir was du liegst und ich zeige
dir wer du bist
computer können muster erkennen die
unser gehirn nicht erkennen kann
der amerikanische psychologe michael
kosinski weiß wie sich ein mensch durch
leuchten lässt unsere persönlichkeit
funktioniert erschreckend stereotyp das
menschliche verhalten ist nicht zufällig
wenn jemand im job freundlich sozial und
charmant ist ist er wahrscheinlich auch
zu hause so unsere entscheidungen sind
nicht zufällig wir sind vorhersehbar und
das ist auch im netz so mit wenigen
klicks weiss kuczynski nicht nur was wir
alles mögen sondern eben auch wie wir
sind
unser modell kann anhand von zehn
facebook likes die persönlichkeit eines
menschen gleich gut beschreiben wie
deren arbeitskollegen anhand von 100
likes sogar besser als freunde und
familienmitglieder zum beispiel mir ein
computer algorithmus ordnet ihre likes
fünf persönlichkeitsmerkmale zu dem
sogenannten big five modell eine gängige
persönlichkeitsanalyse für mir rechnet
es folgendes aus ihre abenteuerlust hält
sich in grenzen
sie macht nicht gerne neue erfahrungen
das merkmal offenheit ist schwach
ausgeprägt
all das kann kuczynski mit seinem
computer modell herausfinden
das so als auch teil ihres
geschäftsgeheimnisses herr kostet eine
methodologie entwickelt weitere
psychologen haben das kommerzialisiert
und aufgrund größerer datensätze ihnen
angeboten um dann wähler konzentriert
und vor allem mit fake news und angst
heischenden kampagnen werbung zu
torpedieren
ja etwas von beängstigenden dass ich bei
cambridge analytiker beobachtete war wie
es psychologen gelangen neurotiker zu
identifizieren die am unteren ende des
big five modells stehen
anhand dieses modells kann man bestimmen
wie emotional menschen auf beängstigende
nachrichten reagieren
so identifizierte mann neurotiker in der
kampagne für john bolton oder in der
superbike kampagne vertrauen
ich bin ein angst belegt der neurotiker
und weiß noch nicht ob ich mich für
anschreiben oder fünf grad clinton
entscheiden will
dann kommt zu mir aufgrund des profil
zur facebook fast genau was für eine
werbung sehen vielleicht etwas furcht
erregendes mit düsteren bildern und
unheilschwangere musik man zeigt ihnen
etwas von dem man weiß dass es sie
beunruhigt in einem john bolton video
das man bürgern zeigte die sich und die
nationale sicherheit sorgten flatterten
weiße flaggen auf amerikas großen
berühmten
und es hieß die usa haben sich noch nie
unterworfen und werden es auch jetzt
nicht tun
damit wollte man suggerieren dass die
usa in den krieg ziehen oder eine
militaristische außenpolitik betreiben
müssten so etwas bekommen sie vielleicht
zu sehen
das verleitet sie dazu das video mit
anderen zu teilen oder einen verärgerten
kommentar an ihre freunde zu schicken
solche aktivitäten interessieren die da
die wissenschaftler haben vor
und das ist die art von aktivität die
sie auch unternommen haben
identifizierung der menschen an sprache
der menschen so dass sie ihr
wahlverhalten in ihrem oder dem sinne
ihres kunden abwälzen jetzt kann man
sagen
gut das ist werbung der neuen art sie
ist gezielter sie hat eine neue methode
aber daran ist ja erst mal gar nichts
leider ist das verbreiten solcher
botschaften an sich nichts illegales
aber einige der strategien dahinter
gelten so viel ich weiss bereits als
illegal
oder sollten es sein so ist aktive wahl
behinderung illegal wenn man angst
machende botschaften verbreitet um leute
dazu zu bringen sich nicht mehr in der
politik zu engagieren der regierung
nicht zu vertrauen nicht wählen zu gehen
ist das ein großes problem
man kann sich leicht vorstellen dass es
eine grauzone rechtlich ist weil wo
beginnt die information die
desinformation wo beginnt die aufklärung
und wo beginnt die die motivierung von
lee prüfern wlan das ist ja gar nicht so
fest einzukreisen oder wie mein buch und
auch unser dokumentarfilm the break
aufzeigt greifen die heutigen
wahlgesetze zu kurz denn es ist sehr
schwierig diese gesetze und bestimmungen
online durchzusetzen
vor allem wenn mark zuckerberg und
facebook nicht eben kooperativ sind ist
das eigentlich so sie haben ja dort
gearbeitet die methode bekannt hat man
mit ihnen auch solche tests gemacht
wissen sie zum beispiel massiven
persönlichkeitstyp sind ich galt als
abenteurerin als sehr extrovertiert und
aufgeschlossen
das heißt ich tanke energie wenn ich mit
anderen menschen zusammen bin ich gehe
gern in die welt hinaus um sie zu
erforschen und neue erfahrungen zu
sammeln
ich bin kaum neurotisch und habe selten
angst was gut ist angesichts der vielen
entscheidungen die ich täglich fällen
muss dieser persönlichkeitstyp heißt
abenteurer unsere psychologen haben 32
verschiedene typen identifiziert
sie sind ja dann auf ein ganz
persönliches abenteuer gekommen sie
waren bei der obama kampagne als
freiwillige tätigt haben dort auch schon
e mail bereichen digitalen bereich
gearbeitet kamen mit herrn nix in
kontakt und sind dann kann man sagen auf
die dunkle seite der macht gewechselt
das heißt ihre abenteuerlust ihre
offenheit hat sie auch immer moralisch
korrumpiert kann man das sagen
das ist das schwierigste wenn du zu
whistleblowern wirst du musst etwas
erfahren haben dass du dann lieben
kannst
ich brauchte etwas länger als ich
rückblickend gehofft hätte um zu
realisieren wie dunkel die mächte waren
die mich umgaben
dieser begriff des whistleblower ist es
ja auch ein relativ unscharf verbreiter
begriff in ihrem fall war es jetzt so
dass tage bevor sie entschieden haben
mit ihren informationen an die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen
ihr name schon in der öffentlichkeit war
mit illegalen praktiken es ging ein
wahlkampf in nigeria das heißt sie waren
in der situation dass ihre firma unter
druck sie persönlich unter druck waren
auch rechtlich unter druck und dann
haben sie entschieden zu sagen jetzt
reicht es ich arbeitete bereits mit
journalisten zusammen weil ich meine
dokumente veröffentlichen wollte
und ich dachte was chris wallace oslo
blauer getan hatte war genau richtig
er arbeitete vor mir bei cambridge
analytiker und stieg aus als ich dort
anfing und ich realisierte mit dem was
er legte gab er der öffentlichkeit der
presse und den ermittlern ein paar teile
des puzzles aber nicht den rest der
geschichte
das zwang mich also praktisch dazu nicht
zu sagen
ist alles andere was passiert ist und
was ich mitbekam
davor muss man die leute warnen das
müssen die ermittler genauer prüfen
denn ich habe beweise für dinge die auf
der ganzen welt getan wurden und es ist
nur richtig dass alle wissen was
passiert der saal haben über dieses
abenteuer das sie danach erlebt haben
dokumentarfilm der jetzt für den oscar
nominiert wurde
wir sehen ihn hier wurde von netflix
produziert was man dort sieht auch ist
ihre situation nachdem sie nach thailand
geflohen sind
in dem moment passiert so viel auf
einmal zum beispiel der börsenwert von
facebook fällt um 100 milliarden dollar
innerhalb von wenigen tagen
sie wissen dass sie für die tram
kampagnen und ihrer information einige
vater stellen ist man so einer situation
auch so dass man angst um sein leben
wenn sie öffentlich sagen die brics it
kampagne und die trump kampagne sein
vielleicht illegal geführt worden
sollten sie sich zumindest bewusstsein
wie viele fanden sich gerade gemacht
haben ich wusste nicht wie die us
regierung oder die britische regierung
meine enthüllungen aufnehmen ich
entschied also zu recht in ein drittland
aus zu reisen und dort zu bleiben bis
ich wusste ob man mit mir
zusammenarbeiten würde oder ob ich
physische gewalt oder den verlust meiner
freiheit befürchten musste dass erleben
heutzutage viele wessel blauer was ja
auch interessant ist an dieser
vernetzung von informationen doch ein
netzwerk der manipulation gab der brh
exit kampagne von neues fahrrad war eng
mit steve barron wiederum eng mit den
finanz kräften hinter cambridge
analytiker
das heißt das war eine insgesamt großes
netz von menschen die diese neuen
technologien zu ihren zwecken
missbraucht haben man könnte fast von
einer art weltweiten verschwörung
sprecher was war ja keine verschwörung
es war einfach eine form techniken die
am markt vorhanden waren zu nutzen
das nehme ich an aber es ist wichtig
dass die leute realisieren nicht die
werkzeuge an sich sondern deren anwender
den schaden an technologische
errungenschaften sind gut bis sich
jemand die bösen absichten zugang
verschafft wenn wir also darüber
nachdenken die anwendung von
technologien gesetzlich zu regulieren
muss uns bewusst sein dass man die leute
zu ethischem umgang mit diesen
werkzeugen zwingen muss sonst kann alles
mögliche passieren
der anstieg von rechtsextremismus
rassismus sexismus diskriminierung im
internet anstiftung zur gewalt dem sind
die leute momentan ausgesetzt und zwar
weil die größte kommunikationsplattform
der welt beschlossen hat politische
äußerungen nicht zu zensurieren hospiz
wird man sie denn heute fragen würde wie
wirksam diese neuen instrumente sind
würden sie sagen dass donald trump
präsident wäre ohne chemisch analytiker
und würden sie sagen dass der exit ohne
camping politiker auch stattgefunden
hatte anders gefragt waren sie und ihre
methoden pause hat für diese ereignisse
es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass ein
wahlkampf sehr komplex und aus vielen
puzzleteilen zusammengesetzt ist
würde man ein element wegnehmen wäre bei
einem so kleinen vorsprung wie in trump
hatte eine kampagne kaum erfolgreich ich
bin überzeugt wenn cambridge analytiker
nicht in die beiden kampagnen involviert
gewesen wäre hätten sie nicht gewonnen
nicht ohne das raffinierte daten target
aber auch nicht ohne den kampagnenleiter
oder gewisse leute aus dem presseteam
es gibt ja auch innerhalb der
psychologie und innerhalb der daten
wissenschaft zweifel daran wie wirksam
dieses targeting mit den
persönlichkeitsstrukturen eigentlich ist
haben sie denn gute empirische hinweise
gesehen dass das um sehr viel höheren
faktor wirksam ist als alles andere das
heißt ist diese marke formel wirklich
magisch oder war das teil ihres
geschäftsmodells sie als magisch zu
präsentieren technologie erscheint wie
magie wenn man nicht versteht wie sie
funktioniert aber etwas muss die
allgemeinheit unbedingt wissen
cambridge analytiker bestand aus einem
team von daten wissenschaftlern die an
den besten universitäten der welt
abgeschlossen hat alles was sie
ausgeklügelten
testeten sie immer wieder bis sie
belegen konnten dass gewisse strategien
funktionierten und dann steckten sie
mehr geld in diese strategien um sie
weiter zu entwickeln
firmenintern sahen wir was funktioniert
und was nicht
warum wir welche entscheidungen trafen
warum wir geld in gewisse strategien
oder kampagnen steckten
es gab tonnenweise empirische beweise in
den hain zahl sehen sie dass es viele
fallstudien mit nummern und beispielen
gibt die genau aufzeigen wie diese wahl
siege errungen wurden sie haben sicher
viel darüber nachgedacht weil das ihr
beruf was eine person dazu bringt sich
selbstbestimmt zu entscheiden was macht
denn für sie eine selbstbestimmte
entscheidung aus im gegensatz zu einer
manipulierten ich finde es ist
heutzutage schwierig entscheidungen
völlig autonom zu treffen
viele scheinen nicht zu merken dass für
die meisten inhalte die wir sehen von
irgendwem irgendwo geld bezahlt wurde
uns diese ideen den kopf zu setzen oder
jenen inhalt bewusste markanteil waren
es nicht zufällig das ist ganz genau
bezahlt und dirigiert an sie ja das habe
ich vor ein paar tagen aufgezeigt anhand
von gesponserten inhalten der tramp
kampagne und der lobbygruppe super pack
die ich als beispiele veröffentlicht
hatte da konnte man sehen wie eine
anzeige auf der website der us zeitung
politico überzeugt ware leser ins visier
nahm doch sie sah nicht wie eine anzeige
aus sondern war so gestaltet dass sie
daher kam wie ein nachrichteninhalt der
zeit der leser wähnte sich auf der
webseite von politik war aber auf einer
von der tramp kampagne finanzierten
anzeige gelandet die hillary clinton und
ihre stiftung der korruption bezichtigt
heute wissen wir dass sind alles fake
news verleumdungen und beleidigungen
wenn das us justizministerium hat
hillary clinton und ihre stiftung
kürzlich entlastet alle diese vorwürfe
entbehrten also jeder grundlage
und waren nachweislich völlig falsch
die sich auch noch als journalismus
ausgaben für die gezahlt wurde von einer
kampagne
man sieht das auch bei modezeitschriften
in allen formen in denen menschen etwas
kaufen oder für sich etwas entscheiden
sollen was ist denn wenn ich jetzt mich
als alexander nix ihr chef imaginären
sage ich höre das alles aber guck es ist
so wir machen werbung irgendwoher müssen
die menschen ihre informationen haben es
gibt so was wie wertfrei information
nicht unter job ist es die informationen
viel der kunde zahlt zielgerichtet zu
platzieren und sonst machen wir gar
nicht ich nehme an das ist so und die
werbeindustrie macht das seit sie
existiert es überrascht nicht dass jeder
industriezweig den informationsgehalt
von daten nutzt das ist nichts
schlechtes
solange man damit nicht ihre freiheit
autonomie oder physische sicherheit
gefährdet aber wir sind nun an einem
punkt wo sehr viele daten von uns im
umlauf sind gleichzeitig ist diese
industrie überhaupt nicht reglementiert
ihre daten können weltweit gekauft und
irgendjemanden verkauft werden der nicht
aus dem land ist wer weiß was für
absichten damit hat der fall müssen wir
uns an die existierenden gesetze halten
und dafür sorgen dass sie umgesetzt
werden und wir müssen firmen und
regierungen helfen diese neuen gesetze
zu befolgen und zu verstehen dass wir
die individuen die diese daten
produzieren schützen müssen bevor wir
ihre daten weiter nutzen
also es gibt eine zone in der das
legales und eine die illegal ist das
problem an cambridge politiker war ja
nicht die technik an sich zunächst
sondern die art und weise wie daten
verwendet wurden
vielleicht schauen wir uns zunächst
einmal an wie facebook eigentlich daten
sammelt eben jene daten die sie dann
verwendet haben
facebook saugt alles von uns auf
nicht nur die daten die wir auf dem
profil selbst eingeben die
beispielsweise geburtstag oder wohnort
auch wenn wir auf anderen internetseiten
surfen und gleichzeitig bei facebook
eingeloggt sind hört die plattform mit
und registriert was uns beschäftigt oder
interessiert wenn wir das facebook app
auf unserem smartphone installiert haben
speichert es mehr als man denkt es läuft
im hintergrund weiter und registriert
unsere bewegungen und wege wenn wir also
beispielsweise mit dem zug von zürich
nach bern fahren merkt dass auch
facebook
frau kaiser viele leute die diese
plattform wenn wissen selbst dass nicht
ich habe hier mein facebook-account
dabei in form eines mobile phones weiß
facebook moment wo ich bin
ich weiß nicht ob sie kürzlich ihre
datenschutz-einstellungen kontrolliert
haben
aber sie sollten vermutlich die
nutzungsbestimmungen die sie akzeptiert
haben nochmals oder zum ersten mal lesen
denn die meisten nutzer realisieren
nicht dass sie mit dem anklicken dieses
kästchens einen vertrag unterschreiben
ich weiß nicht ob sie einen vertrag auf
papier ungelesen unterschreiben wir alle
menschen und sie würden nie einen
vertrag auf papier ungelesen
unterschreiben
aber genau das haben sie getan ich hatte
sechs jahre lang eine facebook-app mir
auf meinem handy weil ich die
nutzungsbestimmungen gelesen habe und
facebook sehr oft ändert obwohl ich
lange jura studiert habe bat ich mich
schwer mit der juristensprache mit der
facebook dich austrickst damit du mehr
preisgibt als gewiss daher mein rat
hätten sie nicht nur die
nutzungsbestimmungen von facebook
sondern auch von allen anderen apps auf
generiert und was jetzt moment offenbar
auch generiert sind sogenannte data
points das heißt informationen über mich
als individuum diese data points wurden
zu dateien die verkauft wurden und es
gab eine besonders diabolische
komponente dabei und die bestand darin
dass über fragebogen die facebook
angeboten hat man etwas unter 2
etwas diejenigen die diese fragebogen
als app präsentierten zugriff auf nicht
nur meine eigenen daten ermöglicht
sondern alle daten meiner freunde ohne
dass die freunde davon gewusst hätten
und das heißt das heißt wenn man das
gemacht hat hat facebook nicht nur meine
daten gehabt sondern die von 500 800 so
viel freunde ich eben habe daten auch
das war der große explosive teil meiner
ersten enthüllungen von cambridge
analytiker durch das mittlerweile
berüchtigte daten portal friends ep
eignet sich der facebook jedem
entwickler sehr für den zugang zu
facebook bezahlte nicht nur an die daten
von nutzern zu gelangen die sich in
computerspielen die farmville oder kandy
crash einloggen oder ins quiz welche
disney prinzessin bist du musikgeschmack
zum beispiel ist oder so genau
sie stimmen also den
nutzungsbestimmungen zu und loggen sich
ein
natürlich hat facebook den zugang zu
ihren daten
aber irgendwie ermöglichte dieses tool
auch den zugang zu allen daten ihre
freunde ihrem netzwerk sei ihre mutter
ihre großmutter ihre kinder und da
begann das problem erst richtig es gibt
keine rechtlichen rahmen bestimmungen
die erlauben dass ich im namen eines
mündigen erwachsenen einer sache
zustimmen
und ganz bestimmt nicht der herausgabe
von daten minderjähriger und das problem
beschränkt sich nicht auf dieses
beispiel mehr als 40.000 firmen hat man
zugang zu diesem entwicklerprogramm
nicht nur cambridge analytiker dass ein
kleines tech startup war
womöglich können millionen firmen
weltweit immer noch auf dieses
facebook-daten set zu greifen dass sie
unrechtmäßig erworben haben und was
cambridge analytiker auf den weg selbst
eine milliarden firma zu werden dann zu
fall gebracht hat war die tatsache dass
diese datenverwendung 2015 illegal wurde
und kritiker diese datensätze für die
usa weiter verwendet hat und 80
millionen profile von usern hatte die
dann gezielt angesprochen wurden das war
doch eigentlich das was alles ins rollen
gebracht hat das war eines der größten
probleme aber nicht nur in den usa
weltweit gibt es länder
die facebook dafür belangen dass ihre
bürger in diesem daten z waren
problematisch ist nicht nur dass die
daten gesammelt wurden sondern dass es
hieß man würde sie für die
wissenschaftliche forschung verwenden
während sie natürlich von allen für
politische oder werbe technische zwecke
eingesetzt wurden und wusste facebook zu
dieser zeit von diesen missbräuchlichen
gebrauch seiner daten
ich glaube nicht dass sie es damals als
missbrauch sahen
für sie war es eine anwendung und sie
wollten geld damit machen was leider
alle ihre entscheidungen antrag
das hat ja zumindest für herrn
zuckerberg persönlich wie für die firma
auch große konsequenzen er wurde
vorgeladen in einer untersuchung zu der
tramp komplett und wir schauen uns mal
kurz an was er dort vor dem komitee von
sich gegeben hat ich denke ich dass er
oft die wahrheit sagt wenn er öffentlich
statements abgibt leider wenn er
angesichts dieses massiven problems sagt
man habe das ausmaß der verantwortung
nicht erkannt spielt er das ganze
herunter er stellt es als fehler da aber
es ist ein verbrechen gegen die
menschheit
und es hat so viele folgen für die
nutzer aber nicht für morgen tatsächlich
ist er reicher als bevor das ganze
desaster seinen anfang nahm
der wert von facebook ist gestiegen und
jedes mal wenn das unternehmen gebüßt
wird steigt sein wert weil alle medien
darüber berichten
zuckerberg wird also durch seine
probleme reicher ich achte senatorin
elizabeth warren für ihren vorstoß
letztes jahr im kongress den corporate
executive accountability act
das heißt wir durch fahrlässigkeit wie
im fall von facebook und akku packs eine
verletzung der datensicherheit begeht
muss sich neu vor dem strafrecht nicht
nur vor dem zivilrecht verantworten
ich denke führungsleute werden in
zukunft internet sicherheit und
datenschutz abkommen stärker
berücksichtigen
denn sie befürchten müssen im gefängnis
zu landen weil sie ihre nutzer nicht
geschützt haben leider ist das passiert
denn wenn bei tech sitzen kräfte tun
können was sie wollen treffen sie
nachweislich keine ethischen
entscheidungen aber es ist ja noch eine
sache etwas zu vernachlässigen und die
andere aktiv wegzuschauen wenn man weiß
die anderen machen das und solange sich
nicht zu bewegen wie es einen selber
nicht betrifft ja ein wichtiges beispiel
neben facebook ist akkupacks ich war die
einzige experten die im ersten
erfolgreichen fall als zeugin gegen
ergriff ex aussagt ist ein großes
finanzdienstleistungsunternehmen die
meisten meinen seine aufgabe sei einfach
der seine kreditwürdigkeit zu
assistieren damit du ein darlehen oder
eine hypothek für dein haus bekommst
doch activex kann deine kreditwürdigkeit
nur attestieren weil die firma so viele
deiner daten besitzt alles was du tust
was du kaufst wohin du gehst was du
gerne liest all das bestimmt den quarks
co zeigt also wie kreditwürdig du bist
mit einer der wichtigsten kennzahlen für
einen leben überhaupt genau und als ex
gehackt wurde
waren das nicht nur sehr clevere hacker
das unternehmen hatte über 300
sicherheitszertifikate auslaufen lassen
und ihre software updates 8500 mal
übersprungen
das ist mehr als nachlässigkeit fragt
man ja schon danach dass das
irgendjemand tut hat sich denn die lage
seither für rechtlich zum beispiel in
usa überhaupt geändert
wir arbeiten daran
david mathers der anwalt der kläger im
verfahren gegen rk fax sagte die firma
hat so fahrlässig gehandelt als hätte
man im eigenen haus bei ausgeschalteter
alarmanlage die lichter an die tür offen
gelassen
in zukunft wird es also hoffentlich
weniger fälle von grober fahrlässigkeit
geben weil die firmen gesehen haben wie
schwierig es ist mit so einer situation
umzugehen
aber ich habe den eindruck der
abschreckungseffekt für gewisse
führungskräfte war leider nicht stark
genug
wie gesagt solange fehlbare unternehmen
nicht mit strafrechtlichen folgen
rechnen müssen und mit einer
verschmerzbaren buße davon kommen und
zudem viele opfer keine entschädigung
einfordern werden wir keine wirkliche
veränderung sehen sogar diese
strafgelder die jetzt facebook
vielleicht zahlen muss man spricht von
fünf milliarden
das macht der firma an sicher erst mal
relativ wenig auswahl das business
modell selbst unangetastet bleibt genau
hätte die buße 100 milliarden dollar
betragen hätte bei facebook ein
wirklicher wandel eingesetzt
doch wie wir beobachten investieren sie
in falsche bereiche und streiten immer
noch jegliche probleme ab ob schon ihre
plattform eklatante probleme mit daten
und nutzer schutz aufweist
ich weiß nicht ich hoffe einfach dass
unsere gesetzgeber verstehen wie
dringend es ist neue gesetze zur
regulierung der großen
technologieunternehmen zu erlassen und
die bestehenden gesetze weiter zu
entwickeln
nicht nur zum schutz unseres täglichen
lebens sondern um sicherzustellen dass
unsere demokratie in fortbestehen
was man eigentlich ja gar nicht
verstehen kann es gibt diese technologie
sagen wir seit 20 jahren sie sind damit
aufgewachsen
für mich kam sie als 20-jähriger in mein
leben seit 20 jahren die
dass diese technologie und es gibt immer
noch keine gesetzgebungen die die neue
situation effektiv adressieren können
das ist ja auch ein versagen des
gesetzgebers selbst ich denke es ist
verfrüht von einem versagen zu sprechen
wenn wir konnten nicht vorhersehen dass
die großen technologieunternehmen solche
monopole giganten würden natürlich
beschuldige ich unternehmen wie facebook
und google nicht weil sie stärker als
erwartet gewachsen sind
klar können da unvorhersehbare probleme
auftauchen das weiß ich von cambridge
analytiker das als kleines start-up
begann explodierte und weltweit
erfolgreich war
die kontrolle dann verlor über sich
selbst und die kontrolle verloren
cambridge analytiker ist ein kleinerer
fall als facebook und google
aber dank meiner erfahrung kann ich nach
vielen unter welchem druck unternehmer
stehen weil sie an allen ecken sparen
müssen um die profite an die aktionäre
weitergeben zu können
gewisse unternehmer tun mir leid weil
sie einerseits ihre firma in schwung
halten und ihre belegschaft bezahlen und
andererseits ethische und moralische
entscheidungen treffen müssen auch wenn
das gesetz sie nicht dazu zwingt deshalb
denke ich gesetze und vorschriften
müssen unser moralischer kodex sein denn
wir können nicht hoffen dass
führungskräfte die moral über ihre
profite stellen die legale seite die
kann also nicht so eingeholt werden wie
sie sagen aber es gibt auch die
persönliche es ist ja offenbar so sie
waren zb im hauptquartier der tramp and
project alamo wo leute von twitter von
facebook von google aktiv genau neben
ihrem team saßen und zusammen die daten
so manipulierten dass sie diese
verheerenden wirkung im sinne von
manipulativen wirkungen haben konnten
sie sind doch einmal in diesen raum
reingegangen und haben sich nicht mal
gefragt was passiert ja eigentlich und
wer bin ich der das leitet ich war in
diesem raum nicht zugelassen
ich war nie in san antonio zur zeit der
tramp kampagnen
wer für die trump kampagne oder im super
pass arbeitete war hinter einer art
feiern
da nicht was sie täglich taten dann
wurde nicht über ihre strategien
informiert war nicht in ihrem e mail
verteiler nicht an ihren telefon
konferenzen und meetings deshalb hatte
ich meinen offenbarung moment beim
debriefing einen monat später wenn wir
bestimmten unsere kollegen nach trumps
wahlsieg wie habt ihr das geschafft was
ist passiert wir wollen die tools sehen
die er benutzt habt und wissen was ihr
für projekte gemacht habt erst einen
monat später im dezember 2016 wurde mir
das ganze ausmaß bewusst das war
ziemlich verstörend cambridge alt er ist
geschichte
diese firma gibt es nicht mehr die
praktiken gibt es noch das kompetente
personal gibt es noch wo sind denn die
alle hingegangen
viele meiner früheren kollegen tun immer
noch das gleiche
sie haben jetzt ihre eigenen politischen
beratungsfirmen
also gibt es anstelle der großen
cambridge analytiker ein paar mini
versionen gegründet von den ehemaligen
angestellten doch noch viel
erschreckender ist wie stark sich die
anwendung dieser strategien auf der
ganzen welt verbreitet hat
laut einer studie welche die oxford
university vor ein paar monaten
herausgab gibt es weltweit hunderte von
firmen die propaganda als dienstleistung
anbieten und sie sind schlimmer als
cambridge analytiker denn sie haben in
neue verbesserte technologien investiert
die cambridge analytiker meines wissens
nie verwendet so kreierten sie
massenweise falsche benutzerkonten bot
fonds und troll fabriken dieser
entwicklungen der künstlichen
intelligenz welche die sozialen medien
so vergiften social media social
business post von dem philosophen rené
girard gibt es die sogenannte sündenbock
theorie wann immer etwas schlechter
neuer kultur läuft muss man auf einen
zeigen ihn umbringen damit die anderen
sich gereinigt führen und war kritiker
nicht vielleicht einfach einen
sündenbock war die praktiken gehen ja
offenbar einfach weiter sie gehen nicht
nur weiter ich denke es ist noch viel
schlimmer als 2016 die firmen sahen das
cambridge analytiker erfolgreich war im
gewinnen von kampagnen und von business
projekten
daher wenden sie nun die gleichen
strategien an
und noch haben wir nicht viele
instrumente um sie zu stoppen oder zu
erkennen
diese strategien angewendet werden wann
dieses targeting stattfindet deshalb
gebe ich viele kurse in digitaler
kompetenz
ich kläre über daten rechte auf und
zeige wie man einfache
sicherheitsprotokolle erstellt um sich
online zu schützen
die unterrichte medienkompetenz damit
man fake news and laufen kann
ich bringe kindern bei sich vor cyber
mobbing zu schützen und sich im internet
ethisch zu verhalten
das alles sollte man wissen bevor man
ein digitales gerät in die hand nimmt
das haben wir vor ein paar jahrzehnten
nicht bedacht dieser informationelle
analphabetismus und ich würde sicher
einer dieser analphabeten seien der ist
ja extrem weit verbreitet bevor wir dazu
kommen wir sind wirklich sehr
interessantes thema sie sitzen derzeit
im aufsichtsrat einer firma die fahne
heißt in texas auswählen und diese firma
wird in zusammenhang gebracht mit geo
lokation daten mit daten die messen wo
man es und soll angeblich für die tram
cup in diesem moment arbeiten was sagen
sie dazu
stellt deshalb bin ich nicht in ihrem
aufsichtsrat ich war mit ihnen im
gespräch doch bevor ich den vertrag
bekam erfuhr ich dass sie für trump
arbeiten und stieg aus den verhandlungen
aus so sind momentan nicht mehr für
fannie mae im aufsichtsrat offiziell war
ich das kann man das nämlich sehen unser
aufsichtsrat mit andi kaiser ja meine
anwälte befassen sich damit also da gibt
es noch ein
aber sie würden sagen jetzt von ihrem
selbst eigene standpunkt und auch von
den erfahrungen die sie gemacht haben in
solch einer firma will ich nicht nur
aufsichtsrat sein ich will damit nichts
mehr zu tun nicht mehr von wordpress
sich an als unternehmen das an die on
your data strategie glaubte und seine
daten an die konsumenten zurückgeben
will
sie kreierten eine blog the wall at app
die anzeigt welche deiner persönlichen
daten eine firma besitzt und immer wenn
deine daten genutzt werden bekommst du
eine dividende
sobald du das recht hast deine daten zu
löschen oder nicht mehr zu teilen wer
über zwei milliarden benutzerkonten hat
dachte ich toll dass es ein
börsenkotiertes unternehmen gibt das
diese aufgabe ernst nimmt und beweisen
will
sie funktioniert diese neue
informationen die für sie sehr
problematisch war offenbar ich habe
durch einen journalisten erfahren dass
sie für die trump kampagne arbeiten
sie haben mich nie auf diesen eklatanten
interessenskonflikt hingewiesen
da erklärte ich ihnen in einem scharf
formulierten e mail ich könne nicht
länger mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
was mich und das ist ja das was sie
gerade gesagt haben diese form sich als
individuum dagegen irgendeiner form zu
schützen wird zur wehr zu setzen meine
töchter
die wollen auf möglichen apps sein die
wollen mit ihren freunden in verbindung
sein ich selber will auf facebook und
auf twitter seien aus beruflichen
gründen was kann ich denn eigentlich tun
ich bin ja aufgrund der sozialen macht
dieser netzwerke vollkommen ausgeliefert
deshalb denke ich dass wirksamste das
alle tun können ist sich selbst zu
informieren
also digitale intelligenz zu erwerben
ein neuer globaler standard heißt
anstatt eine kurve eq also digitaler
intelligenz quotient dieser neue patient
wird nun in den schulen eingeführt so
dass nicht nur kinder sondern auch
eltern und lehrpersonen und hoffentlich
bald auch gesetzgeber und
regierungsbeamte wirklich verstehen
können womit sie als nutzer verführt
werden wie solche inhalte daher kommen
wie kann ich merken ob jemand geld in
einem ring halt gesteckt hat wie kann
ich verstehen ob etwas real ist oder
gezielt an mich geschickt wurde um
einblick in meine daten zu bekommen um
mich wütend zu machen oder nicht so
etwas zu verleiten dass ich sonst nicht
getan hätte die schulung der digitalen
intelligenz ist also das beste werkzeug
um sich zu schützen
leider wird ist einige jahre dauern bis
firmen wie facebook die instrumente und
den willen entwickelt haben um diese
probleme zu bekämpfen
ich werde mir vor sie hätten achtjährige
tochter sowie ich töchter habe
und die wollen auf what's up die wollen
auf instagram die wollen auf tik tok was
weiß ich die wollen diese erst haben wir
ihre freundin sie haben und sie wollen
dabei sein und sie sind jetzt die mutter
dieses kindes was sagen sie denn das
würde ihr empfehlen
nicht alles zu glauben was sie sieht ich
würde ihm raten so wenig zeit wie
möglich am bildschirm zu verbringen und
stattdessen die natur zu genießen und
mit anderen kindern also mit realen
personen zu spielen
ich würde sie auch ermahnen alles was
sie online sieht mit vorsicht zu
genießen
es gibt leute die sich hinter inhalten
verstecken und die tatsache dass ich
ihnen nie etwas böses ins gesicht sagen
aber vielleicht etwas schlechtes in den
sozialen netzwerken über sie verbreiten
würde ist ein riesiges problem vor allem
für die psyche eines kindes es gibt
probleme weil kinder dinge die sie
online sehen zu ernst nehmen
das gefährdet ihre emotionale und
psychische gesundheit
das ist ein großes problem natürlich
betrifft es auch erwachsene aber schlimm
es ist vor allem für kinder die auch
verbieten zu sagen nein du bist meine
tochter ich weiß was da passiert du
gehst da nicht hin auch wenn du allein
bist auch wenn deine freunde die ich
nicht kontaktieren wollen das ist es
wert
ich denke die bildschirmzeit für kinder
zu begrenzen ist unglaublich wichtig
zudem sollten gute eltern ihre kinder
nicht einfach mit einem digitalen gerät
spielen lassen ohne ihnen zu zeigen wie
sie sich schützen können
denn wenn sie unbedingt zugang zu etwas
haben wollen schaffen sie es früher oder
später also müssen wir sie mit den
nötigen werkzeugen ausrüsten
damit sie clevere konsumenten von online
daten werden dann können sie fundiert
und individuell entscheiden was sie
glauben und fühlen wollen sie sind ja
schon oft an einer neuen bewegung man
sieht es an ihrer halskette own your
data als die das heißt ihr ansatz ist
all die daten die wir freiwillig
unterschrieben vertraglich an facebook
an google an all diese firmen geben mit
denen sie ihr geschäftsunterlagen die
sollten wir nicht denen überlassen
sondern wir sollten sie für uns haben
es sollte ein privater sitzt jeder
person verstehe ich das richtig
ganz genau diese daten produzieren wir
sie sind unser menschlicher wert jeden
tag schaffen wir das wertvollste gut auf
der erde und das wurde uns entzogen
in der vergangenheit wurden wehrlose
populationen ausgenutzt
natürlichen ressourcen öl gold oder was
auch immer
aus heutiger sicht missbilligen wir
dieses verhalten wie schauen wir später
mal auf diese technologische revolution
zurück wie fühlen wir uns wenn wir nach
vielen jahrzehnten dieses beinahe
desaster analysieren
ich denke wir werden ähnlich empfinden
sie bei diesen historischen beispiel das
beste was wir also tun können ist sicher
zu stellen wir produzenten des
kostbarsten der welt haben recht daten
rechte sind unglaublich wichtig ich
finde sie sollten so grundlegend sein
wie menschenrechten und sie müssen
durchsetzbar sein wenn sich jemand meine
daten missbräuchlich aneignet will ich
ihm rechtlich belangen können und in den
meisten ländern sind eigentumsrechte am
besten geschützt
wie gesagt wenn sie in mein haus
einbrechen kann ich sie rechtlich
belangen und entschädigt werden
ich sehe die zukunft der daten rechte
wie ein alien
will jemand zugang zu ihrem haus einem
ihre kostbarsten güter muss er ihnen
sagen wer ist wofür und lange er das
haus nutzen will
sie machen einen preis aus und werden
bezahlt bevor sie in den schlüssel
überreichen
wie wäre es damit und also eine firma
diese selbst gegründet haben die mit
form der plogg chain technologie einer
technologie dafür besonders geeignet ist
im prinzip sagt wir holen eure daten
zurück so dass sie euch gehören werden
und ich denke die block chain
technologie ist momentan eine unserer
größten hoffnungen wenn es darum geht
wie wir unsere daten sichern können
wir könnten eine app auf unserem handy
haben uns alle daten auf zeigt die wir
produzieren
so können wir entscheiden ob wir sie
geheim halten oder mit firmen und
organisationen teilen wollen ich könnte
zum beispiel meine gesundheitsdaten mit
krebsforschern teilen und mithelfen
eines der größten probleme der welt zu
lösen
aber ich muss entscheiden können ob ich
meine privatsphäre schützen oder diese
daten teilen möchte und dann sollte ich
dafür entschädigt werden
das möchte innerhalb dieser bewegung die
sagt daten rechte sind menschenrechte
bürgerrechte sie sollten unter anderem
kontrolle gestellt dann gibt es ja zwei
große schuhe in ihre schule die sagt das
sollte ein privatbesitz seien und eine
andere eher sagen wir weniger
marktorientierte schule gesagt es sollte
einfach rechtlich nicht erlaubt sein
mit gewissen daten gewisse dinge zu tun
was man ihnen vielleicht vorwerfen
könnte wäre das ist wieder das
kapitalistische modell nur dass
derjenige der die daten nutzt jetzt ich
bin und wenn ich die daten habe dann
kann ich sie an facebook verkaufen dann
kann ich sie an twitter verkaufen dann
kann ich sagen eine fremdfirma verkaufen
das heißt das ist ja eigentlich auch ein
marktwirtschaftliches modell nur eben
dass jetzt das individuum davon
profitieren soll
das stimmt in gewisser hinsicht aber wir
müssen ein paar dinge begreifen der
kapitalismus und die märkte werden nicht
verschwinden
und wenn unsere daten unser wertvollstes
gut sind und ich sehe jede sekunde
produzieren dann sollte ich auch zugang
zu diesem markt haben und anerkannt
werden für den wert den ich in diesem
weltweiten markt schaffe richtig zudem
habe ich mich lange genug für die
menschenrechte eingesetzt
ich weiß wie schwer es ist diese vor
gericht durchzusetzen
manchmal dauert es jahre bis zum prozess
manchmal wird der fall abgewiesen
und es ist ein großes problem dass es in
der industrie so schwierig ist mit den
menschenrechts gesetzen gewöhnliche
bürger können firmen wie aphex oder
facebook nicht einfach wegen der
verletzung ihrer menschenrechte
verklagen
viel glück bei der inter amerikanischen
kommission für menschenrechte oder beim
internationalen strafgerichtshof das
einfordern dieser rechte ist schwierig
ich befasse mich jahrelang damit und das
macht ja auch so interessant weil es im
prinzip die geschichte einer idealistin
ist die als menschenrechtsaktivistin
beginnt für ngo aus arbeitet als für
nicht kommen kann man mental
organisations und dann sagt das
funktioniert hier alles nicht und jetzt
da raus zu schluss zählt das geht nur
über privat richte ich denke gesetze und
vorschriften sind der beste rahmen für
die gestaltung unserer
gesellschaftlichen vereinbarungen
was sind unsere moralischen und
ethischen vorstellungen
was für werkzeuge geben wir den menschen
so durchsetzt sein kann wenn ich
verhindern will dass etwas von mir
missbräuchlich verwendet wird und
instrumente brauche um mich zu schützen
macht es zehn verschiedene gesetzes
formate zu nutzen
das hat price ihren nützlich erwiesen
wir haben effects wegen eigentums-
beschädigung angeklagt der erste
erfolgreiche fall gegen ex wurde
angestrengt wegen der schädigung von
daten die den nutzern gehörten das
wendeten wir auf alle anderen fälle an
sie vertraten hunderte von bürgern im
bundesstaat minnesota
die geschädigte von activex waren
angeführt von und sie reichten fall
unfall ein
das ganze gelangte über einen
stadtgericht bis zum obersten gericht
und wir haben gewonnen
der gang durch die institutionen und der
kommerzielle schaden der dadurch
entstehen kann das sind zwei große
stellschrauben wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe
wir sind jetzt 2020 der praxis ist ein
fakt donald trump steht vor einer neuen
wahlkampagne amerika haben sie denn das
gefühl dass irgendetwas im wesentlichen
anders ist als vor dem letzten wahlkampf
oder sind die dinge vielleicht sogar
noch schlimmer ich denke die ganze
kampagnen infrastruktur und die tatsache
dass facebook politiker nicht den
gleichen ethischen regeln unterstellt
sie es mich bedeutet dass 2020 leider
viel schlimmer sein wird als 2016 anders
ist einzig dass impeachment verfahren
gegen donald trump das mag die
einstellung gewisser wähler ändern
doch leider sind viele die trans erste
kampagne geführt haben auch 2020 in
seinem thema dass menschen auch die sie
eingestellt haben im übrigen nicht wahr
einige habe ich eingestellt und
ausgebildet und diese leute werden nicht
nur die gleichen taktiken sondern noch
besser entwickelte tools einsetzen
sie haben mehr daten als zuvor wohl auch
mehr mittel
wir sollten daher angst haben vor dem
was wir von jetzt
racine werden ist es denn eigentlich nur
so dass die eine politische seite das
tut oder ist das einfach
state-of-the-art das was jeder tun muss
wenn er gewählt werden wird also ist es
so dass die demokraten das nicht machen
oder macht das einfach jeder hat auf
seine art
alle nutzen daten für kampagnen sei eine
kommunikations geleitet und keine daten
nutzt versteht nichts von seiner arbeit
doch wie gesagt daten für die
kommunikation zu nutzen ist nicht das
problem es kommt darauf an wie ich habe
weder in jüngster zeit noch je tritt vor
beobachtet dass die demokraten wahl
behinderung taktiken rassismus sexismus
oder diskriminierung in ihrer
politischen werbung eingesetzt hätten
auch nicht diese art der anstifter
gewalt eine eindeutige strategien der
tramp kampagne noch einmal es geht nicht
um die werkzeuge sondern um deren
verwendung
wenn man ihr buch liest ist ein sehr
beeindruckendes zeugnis auch eines
menschen der eine gewisse generation
verkörpert die mit allen utopischen
träumen in dieser atmosphäre gegangen
ist und dann als person auf die dunkle
seite der macht so kann man es ja sagen
gewandelt ist finden sich auch gewisser
weise verantwortlich als symbol einer
ganzen generation die in dieser
beziehung versagt hat sicher spüre ich
die verantwortung meine geschichte
mitzuteilen
die wahrheit ans licht zu bringen so
viele wie möglich auf die probleme und
gefahren diese geräte hinzuweisen und
eine bewegung für veränderung mit
anzuführen
denn das brauchen wir amerikaner wie in
der vergangenheit als öl firmen und
banken und die krise stürzten und dies
neue gesetze und bestimmungen zur folge
hatte das ist jetzt nötig für die
technologiebranche damit wir und die
kommenden generationen geschützt sind
was war danach in der nachbetrachtung
ihres sehr interessanten falls würden
sie sagen ihr größter fehler
mein größter fehler war dass ich nicht
wissen blaue rinn wurde bevor trump die
wahlen gewonnen hat
oder ist zum rexit kam ich wünschte ich
hätte genug beweise gefunden früher an
die öffentlichkeit zu gelangen
und es gab keine stimmen im inneren die
schon sich ab und zu mal nachts gemeldet
hat und gesagt hat das ist doch alles
nicht richtig was hier passiert ich
hätte nie gedacht dass die beiden
kampagnen erfolgreich sein würden
politiker arbeitete für viele kandidaten
weltweit für grüne liberale demokraten
für leute die euch gewählt hätte wenn
ich in diesen ländern wahlberechtigt
wären aber donald trump und die
präsentiert ich fand sie so lächerlich
dass ich nie befürchtete sie könnten
gewinnen
viele leute waffen wie ich es ist daher
sehr wichtig kandidaten ernst zu nehmen
und zu realisieren dass mit den
richtigen tools mit unterstützung und
geld heute jeder gewinnen kann
sagen sie mal
es gibt ja diese wunderbare kategorie
der person die bulls auf dass jedes
wahlkampfteam abzielt waren sie denn
oder sind sie noch ein person selber ich
war sicher eine überzeugt bares als ich
für cambridge analytiker arbeitete wie
der titel meines buches verrät war nicht
zielscheibe und ich war überzeugt die
sache an der ich beteiligt war sei
richtig aufregend und innovativ und ich
können regierungen kandidaten und firmen
etwas wichtiges vermitteln aber wenn mir
das passiert ist kann jeder rhein
gelockt werden und das ist meine warnung
an alle bestimmt gibt es in tech
startups oder unternehmen wie facebook
viele mitarbeiter die dinge sehen mit
denen sie nicht einverstanden sind aber
sie wollen ihre familien ernähren
ihre rechnungen bezahlen und denken
vielleicht kann ich mit diesen tools
eines tages eine große soziale wirkung
erzielen wer aber mehr zeit damit
verbringt demokratien zu unterwandern
stadt zu unterstützen muss sich fragen
was er involviert ist ganz wichtige
einsicht gegen das scheint vielen dank
dass sie uns gezeigt haben wie
manipulationsanfällig anfällig menschen
sind und auch vielleicht was wir in
zukunft dagegen tun kann dann kaputt
sind die kreise
ich danke ihnen und nächste woche
spreche ich mit der mexikanischen
menschenrechtsaktivistin lydia cacho
über die macht der drogenkartelle und
vor allem was diese frauen
lateinamerikas bedeutet bleiben sie also
dran und denken sie weiter
[Musik]